for fun let's try to approximate the
area under the curve y is equal to the
square root the principal root of x
minus 1 between X is equal to 1 and X is
equal to 6 so I want to find this entire
area or I want to at least approximate
this entire area and the way I'll do it
the way I'll do it is by setting up five
trapezoids of equal width so this will
be the starting the the left boundary of
the first trapezoid this will be its
right boundary which will also be the
left boundary of the second trapezoid
this will be the right boundary of the
second trapezoid this is the right
boundary of the third trapezoid this
will be the right boundary of the fourth
trapezoid and then finally this will be
the boundary of the fifth trapezoid and
since we're traveling we're going from 1
to 6 so we're traveling 6 minus 1 in the
X direction and I want to split it into
five sections the width of each
trapezoid is just going to be equal to 1
and so if we say that the width of a
trapezoid is Delta X we just can now say
that Delta X is equal to 1 so let's set
up our trapezoids
so the first trapezoid is going to look
like it's going to look like that it's
going to go like that actually it's
going to be a triangle not really a
trapezoid then the second trapezoid is
going to look like this
you could say a trapezoid where one of
the sides as length 0 turns into a
triangle then this the third trapezoid
is going to look like this and then the
fourth trapezoid is going to look like
that and then finally you have the fifth
trapezoid so let's calculate the area of
each of these and then we will have our
approximation for the area under the
curve so let's do trapezoid or I really
should say triangle this first shape
whatever you want to call it what is the
area of that going to be well the area
of a trapezoid and you'll see this will
just this will just turn into the area
of a triangle it's the average of the
heights of the two sides of the
trapezoid the way we've looked at or you
could say the average of the heights of
the two parallel sides I guess
way to say it so f of one that's the
height here plus F of 2 plus F of 2 all
of that over 2 and then we're going to
multiply it times our Delta X we're
going to multiply it times our Delta X
actually let me do that in that same red
color to show you that this is the area
of that first trapezoid of that first
trapezoid so times Delta X and as you
see right over here if you if you look
at it the F of 1 is just going to be 0
so you're gonna have F of 2 times so
it's going to be that this height times
this space times 1/2 which does which is
just the area of a triangle but let's
look at the second trapezoid trapezoid 2
right over here what is its area going
to be well it's going to be F of 2 it's
going to be F of 2 plus F of 3 F of 2 is
this height F of 3 is this height so
we're taking the average of those two
Heights divided by 2 that's the average
of those two Heights times the base
times Delta X and then let's do
trapezoid 3 I think you're getting the
idea here trapezoid 3 it's going to be F
of 3 plus F of 4 divided by 2 times
Delta X and then let's see I'm running
out of colors this is trapezoid 4 right
over here so plus F of 4 plus F of 5 all
of that over 2 times Delta X and then we
have our last trapezoid which I will do
in yellow so this is trapezoid number 5
scroll down a little bit get some more
real estate so it's going to be plus
I'll just write the plus over here plus
F of 5 plus F of 6 over 2 times our
Delta X so let's see how we can simplify
this a little bit all of these terms we
have a 1/2 Delta X so let's actually
factor that out so remember this is our
approximation of our area so area area
is approximately remember this is just a
rough approximation it's very clear
actually you might say this is pretty
good using the trapezoids but there are
there it is pretty clear
or that we are letting go of some of the
area we're letting go of that area we're
letting go of some of this right over
here you can barely see it some of this
right over here you can barely see it
but we are this is going to be it looks
like an underestimate but it is a decent
approximation let's see if we can
simplify this expression so let's go
approximately going to be equal to I'm
going to factor out a delta x over two
I'm going to factor out a delta x over
two and then what I'm left with and I
will switch to a neutral color if i
factor out a delta x over two then I
have just an F of one F of one and then
I have two F of twos so plus 2 times F
of 2 and I'm doing this because you
might see a formula that looks something
like this in your calculus book and it's
not some mysterious thing they just
really summed up the areas of the
trapezoids and then we're going to have
to F of threes plus 2 times F of threes
plus we're going to have to F of fours
plus 2 times F of 4 and then we're going
to have to F of 5s plus 2 times F of 5
and then finally we're going to have 1 F
of 6 plus F of 6 if you were to
generalize it you have one of the first
endpoint the function evaluated the
first endpoint one of it at the very
last endpoint and then two of all of the
rest of them but this is just the area
of trapples I'm not actually a big fan
when textbooks write this because you
don't when you see this it's hard to
visualize the trapezoids when you see
this it's much clearer how you might
visualize that but with that out of the
way let's actually evaluate this lucky
for us the math is simple our Delta X is
just 1 our Delta X is just 1 and then we
just have to evaluate all of this
business F of 1 let's just remind
ourselves what our original function was
our original function was the square
root of x minus 1 square root of x minus
1 so f of 1 is the square root of 1
minus 1 so that is just going to be 0
this is this expression right over here
is going to be 2 times the square root
of 2 minus 1 the square root of 2 minus
1 is just 1 so this is just going to be
2 actually let me do it in that same
well I'm now using the purple for a
different purpose than just the first
trapezoid hopefully you realize that
just sticking with that pin color then f
of 3 3 minus 1 is 2 square root of 2 so
the function evaluated 3 is the square
root of 2 so this is going to be 2 times
the square root of 2 then the function
evaluated for when you evaluate it for
you get the square root of 3 so this is
going to be 2 times the square root of 3
and then you get 2 times the square root
of 4 5 minus 1 is 4 2 times the square
root of 4 is just 4 and then finally you
get F of 6 is square root of 6 minus 1
is the square root of 5 square root of 5
and I think we are now ready to evaluate
so let me get my handy ti-85 out and
calculate this so it's going to be well
I'm just going to calculate what I'll
just multiply it so 0.5 times open
parenthesis well it's a 0 I'll just
write it just to you know what I'm doing
0 plus 2 whoops
lost my calculator plus 2 times the
square root of 2 plus 2 times the square
root of 3 plus 4 plus 4 I'm almost done
plus plus the square root of 5 so let me
write that plus the square root of 5
gives me now we are ready for our drum
roll it gives me and I'll just round it
7 point 2 6 so the area is approximately
equal to approximately equal to 7 point
to 6 under the curve under the curve Y
is equal to the square root of x minus 1
between x equals 1 and x equals 6 and we
did this using trapezoids